Welcome
to a whole day of my life as a social media director for Dean Butler,
best known as Almanzo slash
Almanzo Wilder from Little House on the Prairie.
This weekend,
my husband Jacob and I jumped in the car and headed to Mansfield,
Missouri, for a special festival they call Wilder Days.
One of the things I really love about doing these events is
I get to meet fans from all across the country
that are obsessed with Little House on the Prairie.
And in the process, I also get to make a lot of fun content for Dean.
This year's the fiftieth anniversary of Little House on the Prairie,
the TV series. And we've traveled to so many different homesteads,
and it's been such a joy to see the way Laura Ingalls Wilder
really lived her life.
And the way people resonate with Laura and her story.
So special, and it feels so nostalgic.
This is me
trying to convince Dean that he should do a video with Gen Z slang.
And if you haven't seen it yet,
you should. And the bloopers are coming,
and they're wonderful. As we wrap up this event,
it's so exciting because Dean's gonna be in Tulsa this week,
so stay tuned for all the Tulsa content coming.